hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the course of his short work what is
art leo tolstoy will first examine a
number of already provided definitions
of art which he rejects and then provide
his own in his view superior definition
that figures art as a means of
communication or communion between the
producer the audience and potentially
other spectators or auditors or whoever
is experiencing the art so it's a mode
of communication
spanning quite a potential distance in
space or time or culture and it also has
to be artefactual it's it's expressed in
outward signs and there's there's also
that the purpose of communication there
so that in an essence is his definition
of art and in Chapter five he's going to
provide this and flesh it out he begins
chapter five first by rejecting other
definitions and he has already examined
a number in earlier chapters based on
Beauty understood is as something that
could be defined or encapsulated in some
way generally relying on some sort of
metaphysics and beauty involving
pleasure so so we get a rejection of
ways of understanding art then
essentially frame it in terms of the
pleasure that is being provided by the
work of art to the spectator or observer
or you might say the the consumer so he
puts that aside and then he says there's
a few other definitions attempts to
characterize art that we need to get out
of the way as well he calls one of these
the physio evolutionary typing and
that's quite interesting he says that
the latest and most comprehend
definitions of our independent of the
concept of beauty would include the
following art is an activity already
emerging in the animal kingdom out of
sexuality and a propensity for play he
says this comes from Schiller Darwin and
Spencer accompanied by a pleasant
excitation of nervous energy grant and
Alan are the people talking about that
so he calls this the physiological
evolutionary definition and he says this
doesn't really work to explain what art
would be it may in fact provide us with
some feature of why artworks are
produced it could be that there is an
element of play there but he says that
it's imprecise because it speaks not of
the activity that constitutes the
essence of art but the the origin of art
and Tolstoy is saying you can have all
that sort of stuff and we could bring in
psychoanalytic discussions as well or
any of that but the origins by
themselves doesn't get us the the
essence the what makes art art now
another interesting attempt that he
talks about he calls the practical
definition of art so he says art is an
external manifestation by means of lines
colors gestures sounds or words of
emotions experienced by man and he says
this comes from viral causes the
practical definition and he says that
the practical definition is imprecise
why because a person can express their
emotions by means of lines colour sounds
and words without affecting others by it
and the expression will then not be art
so there is a audience dependency you
could say so the the piece that is
produced by the
I know let's say musician and it's never
heard by anyone else is it really art
Tolstoy would say no I think a lot of us
would probably say yeah of course it's
just art that's not being heard but
Tolstoy has something else in mind
that he thinks is that the essence of
art then there's a third definition
that's provided and he doesn't give a
name to this but he but he associates
this with Sulli art is the production of
some permanent object or passing action
which is fitted here's a couple
conditions not only to supply an act of
enjoyment to the producer but to convey
a pleasurable impression to a number of
spectators or listeners quite apart from
any personal advantage to be derived
from it so art then becomes something
that gives pleasure both to the person
producing the art that's pleasant to
engage in the art at least at some stage
of it may be the preparatory stuff is
not about that Pleasant right or
shelling out plenty of money for for
colors is not all that Pleasant but the
the production is and then the the
audience the receivers they get some
pleasure out of it and there's no
there's no practical gain in the process
and Tolstoy says well you know that's
not bad but he says under this
definition could be included the
performance of magic tricks gymnastic
exercises and other activities that are
not art and on the other hand many
objects that produce an unpleasant
impression as for example a gloomy cruel
scene and a poetic description er in the
theater are unquestionably works of art
so it fails in in two different ways it
includes too much on the one side and it
fails to include some things that we
would say are definitely art on the
other side so what is Tolstoy going to
offer before we look at that notice that
he's not totally rejecting all of these
and saying those have nothing to do with
art
as a matter of fact when it comes to the
practical the expression of emotion side
of it emotion or feeling is going to
play an important part and expression of
that is going to play an important part
it's just not enough for a definition of
art and providing pleasure K Tolstoy is
is rather suspicious of the pleasant
part but one of the things that the the
Sulli definition does get at is that
there's something going on not just for
the audience but also for the person
producing they're engaged in something
together and in Sully's case he's
talking about pleasure in Tolstoy his
case he's talking about something else
so let's look at Tolstoy his own
characterization or a definition of art
he tells us that the mistake that they
have made is not considering art as one
of the conditions of human life
something absolutely central to human
life so he says if we consider art this
way
we cannot fail to see that art is a
means of what use this word communion
communion among people and then he goes
on and he says every work of art results
in the one who receives it the spectator
the auditor the observer the consumer
entering into a certain kind of
communication with the one who produced
or is producing the art so we're gonna
have a little bit more in just a second
but well think about that what this
means is that genuine works of art works
that are expressive of the very essence
of art are going to be providing
communion whatever that communion is
going to be between the person or
persons who are engaged in producing it
and the audience
could be there at the present time or
could be distant by millennia think
about us and Homer for example when we
read The Iliad now Homer you know of
course people are gonna point out we're
not really sure if there was a single
guy named Homer or if it was sort of an
ensemble of people working at things
that just reinforces Tolstoy point those
producers working through that as a
troop or ensemble or as a bunch of
people over a couple hundred years using
each other's composition would also be
in that communion a growing and
developing communion with each other
so it's a communion among people now
notice what else he says about this
though it's not just between the
producer and the observer it's between
observers and other observers he says
it's communion with all of those who
simultaneously with him before him or
after him have received or will receive
the same artistic impression so it
offers the potentiality of reaching an
audience some of whom are not yet born
and yet who we would be in a kind of
communion with something you know that
that spans the the ages what is this
communion so Tolstoy says that the
communion is essentially about feelings
he says that here we go as the word
which conveys men's thoughts and
experiences serves to unite people so
art serves in precisely the same way but
the peculiarity of this means of
communication is that through the word
or through through art people convey
their feelings to each other so the
activity of art is based on the fact
that people as they receive through
hearing or sight the expression of
another person's feelings is capable of
experiencing the same feelings as the
one
expresses them so when I listen to a
work of music
let's take stuff that's you know kind of
easy low-hanging fruit with this I'm
listening to you know a gorgeous
romantic composition and it's supposed
to convey the feeling of triumph over
adversity or something like that
according to Tolstoy if I'm in communion
through that work of art with the
composer or perhaps we might also say
with the director of the players all the
people who made the the thing that I'm
listening to then they're feeling that
feeling I'm also feeling that feeling as
well
he doesn't specify precisely I mean it
do we feel it like 95 percent
identically or is it does it suffice to
feel it and kind of broad strokes the
same way you know because he doesn't
have to this is something that we could
work out on our own but the feelings are
shared in and he talks about examples of
what he you know has come to be called
emotional infection right but also
sharing the same kind of experience so
he says think about a simple example a
person laughs another person feels merry
he weeps and the person who hears this
weeping feels sad a man is excited
annoyed and another looking at him gets
into the same state with his movements
the sound of his voice a person displays
cheerfulness determination around the
contrary dejection calm and this mood is
communicated to others and he talks
about this capacity of people to be
infected by the feelings of other people
and he says art is based upon this that
doesn't mean that art is entirely that
but that's something essential to art
now is that enough to make it art he
says no there's there's two other
conditions that are going to come up in
here one is that there has to be a
purpose of communicating to others so
the mere fact have come
and being ticked off that you know the
train didn't run on time and I got rain
died and all that and I take off my coat
in an angry way and you know somebody
asks me how are you doing here this day
sucks stupid street car didn't stop
where it was supposed to right that's
not yet art even though it may in fact
be communicating my feeling to the other
person who then according to Tolstoy
would have to get angry or have some
kind of emotional response consonants
with it
due to my my expressing my feelings I
have to have a purpose of communicating
my feelings to other and that's part of
what makes for working in an artistic
medium for somebody like Tolstoy then
that's the other key thing there has to
be an expression as he says by external
signs and he says art begins when a
person with the purpose of communicating
to other people a feeling he wants
experience calls it up again within
himself and expresses it by certain
external signs so he goes on and he says
a little bit later he's talking about a
wide range of feelings he says feelings
the most diverse very strong and very
weak very significant and very worthless
very bad and very good if only they
infect the reader the spectator the
listener constitute the subject of art
the feeling of self-denial and
submission to fate or God portrayed in a
drama the raptures of lovers described
in a novel a feeling of sensuous
described in a painting the briskness
conveyed by a triumphal march and music
the gaiety evoke by a dance the
comicality caused by a funny anecdote
the feeling of peace conveyed by an
evening landscape or lulling song all of
this is art so all of these things
qualify if there is in fact an emotional
communication taking place as art 4/4
Tolstoy and the one last thing that I do
want to talk about with this definition
is the fact that as we've mentioned
earlier this allows you could say
communication over a distance and so he
says that just as owing to our capacity
for understanding thoughts expressed in
words any person can learn all that
mankind has done for them in the realm
of thought can in the present owing to
the capacity for understanding other
people's thoughts participate in other
people's activity and can himself convey
thoughts he's received from others to
his contemporary and his posterity
there's a similar thing going on with
art he says owing to man's capacity for
being infected by other people's
feelings through art he has access to
all that mankind has experienced before
him in the realm of feeling provided as
conveyed through the artwork he has
access to the feelings experienced by
his contemporaries to feelings lived by
other men thousands of years ago and
it's possible for him to convey his
feelings to other people so this was a
very optimistic sort of viewpoint the
communicability of what's going on in
art right genuine art according to
Tolstoy allows us to respond in such a
way as to be able to grasp what's going
on in other people's art now that may be
a little optimistic it may be that we
require some education and training as
he's going to you know talk about a
little bit or not in order to appreciate
and to thereby understand and enter into
communion about what's happening with
the art that other people are doing
particularly if they are distant in in
time or in space or in culture from us
but that's the essence of Tolstoy
understanding of art he thinks that this
provides us with a definition
we really should understand this as a
definition that's meant to be normative
rather than merely descriptive
you